how do you take classroom teaching and
turn that into videos for students to
learn from
I'm Eddie Wu and my youtube channel is
made up of videos that are recorded
during my regular high school classroom
lessons if you're interested in the
equipment that I used to do that check
out the previous video in this video I'm
going to show you how I use all that
gear in the classroom and also what I do
with the footage to make it ready for
upload I know many teachers have their
own designated classroom but for most of
my teaching career I've had to move from
room to room when the bell goes and I
have to teach my next class when my
timetable permits I try to arrive a few
minutes early to set up now I stand my
camera right at the back of the
classroom and then use my zoom lens to
crop as close as I can to the whiteboard
and when I used to film with my phone
I'd stand it around the middle of the
room because that was the best way to
capture my entire whiteboard nowadays
though the camera resolution on a phone
is high enough that I could put it at
the back of the room and then crop the
video frame to just show the teaching
I'll show you how to do that later on
and what I do next depends on the kind
of lesson that I have planned
sometimes I'll hit record at the start
of the lesson and just leave it going
the entire time other times I'll start
and stop the recording to conserve
battery whichever way I do it I want to
make sure the image is in focus and that
the sound is coming through correctly
now before we talk about editing these
videos I want to pause and make a brief
note mine all videos are recorded with
my class in the room as I deliver a
timetable lesson if you want to do this
too then it's important to adhere to the
policies of your school or learning
institution around recording and
publishing content just as an example
all my students are aware that I record
lessons in which you can hear their
voices and they ask me questions or
engage in class discussion and your
organization may have certain rules
around this and it's important that you
ask questions to find out what's
appropriate if you aren't allowed to
record in the classroom there are tons
of other ways to make learning content
one of my favorites is to use the screen
recording function on my iPad to explain
a problem and provide a work solution on
a note-taking app like a notability and
we'll return to that idea at the end of
the video the policies of your
organization may also affect things like
advertisements and monetization
I personally don't monetize my videos
but if you'd like to do this then you
need
to find out about the intellectual
property rights that apply to things so
you create as a teacher I encourage you
to do research and ask questions about
any areas like this we are uncertain
because guidelines will change depending
on your context so now let's get to the
editing I've always kept my editing
workflow very simple for two reasons
I shoot lots of videos and I don't have
lots of time to edit them all I do is
load the video onto my computer and use
software like Final Cut Pro to cut the
footage into appropriately sized chunks
the average length of video on my
channel is around 8 minutes which lines
up pretty well with the attention span I
have for dealing with a single concept
or question when I'm explaining it to my
students I often pause for a few minutes
in the middle of an explanation to let
my students work on a task before I
reengage them with the next part of a
lesson so I usually cut those parts of
the video out because I'm spending time
beside my students at their desks and
you don't see anything on the video
that's relevant to the entire class
explanation it's also worth mentioning
but if you're going to keep your editing
simple like what I've just described
then you can use freely available
software like iMovie which is really
user friendly it's very straightforward
to find the right points on the videos
timeline break it into separate chunks
and then delete the ones you don't want
oh this is also where it's easy to zoom
in and crop the frame of the video if
you need to speaking the iPad as I
mentioned earlier you can make videos
entirely on this device it has a
built-in screen recording function that
lets you capture footage of whatever's
on screen which for me will often be
riding up a solution or visualizing a
function with graphing software the iPad
microphone can record your voice and for
an added bonus you can also use your
phone to capture your face at the same
time I know lots of people don't like to
be seen but I've found that a really
effective component of engaging
communication so that's what my workflow
looks like from the side of a lesson to
the end of editing I always answer keep
it simple and while you can definitely
spend lots of time to make things look
more fancy I try to make content that
speaks for itself in the next video I'll
show you how to upload that content to
YouTube where it can get to business and
help people learn